il gioco a pallavolo da ormai sette anni
da quando ne avevo 11
non starò qui a dirvi cosa significa
vincere o perdere ma vi parlerò di
quelle che sono state le mie di vittorie
e di sconfitte negli anni ho compreso
bene il valore dello sport il valore di
avere un obiettivo di riuscire a puntare
verso quell'obiettivo di rincorrerlo di
non lasciarsi prendere da un senso di
non essere abbastanza perché non è mai
realmente così se tu hai una meta sai a
cosa vuoi arrivare
riuscirai sempre e in qualsiasi modo
anzi nel tuo modo a compiere quello per
cui tanto hai lottato e lo so che ha una
cosa banale da dire che lo dicono in
tanti che se tu hai un obiettivo prima o
poi lo raggiungi ma è realmente così e
lo sport è stata per me la conferma di
tutto ciò di una frase che prima era
quasi insignificante perché una frase
finché non la vivi assi senso ma non per
te e io questo senso la iniziato a
sentire vivo dentro di me da quattro
anni a questa parte fino agli 11 anni ho
praticato l'atletica leggera uno sport
che potremmo semplicemente definire
individuale ci sei tu e basta poi con
l'inizio della prima media ha iniziato
per me un nuovo modo di vedermi con gli
altri la palla vola infatti uno sport di
squadra e tu da solo non vale proprio
nulla se non hai con te almeno altri
cinque persone che si schierano in quel
campo negli anni ho compreso bene che
cos'è la squadra un organismo una
macchina molto complessa qualcosa di
inspiegabile finché non lo vivi la
squadra non è solamente qualcosa di
quegli altri ti vedono parte di cui tu
stesso fai parte comprendi col tempo che
anche tu sei la squadra essere squadra
ecco cos'è la cosa più difficile da
apprendere
e questo concepire il concetto
dell'essere squadra mi ha reso
consapevole di quanto siano importanti
la collaborazione e rispetto degli altri
nella vita
immaginatevi l'impatto che può avere
un'idea del genere in un ragazzino
11 12 anni da quel momento ho continuato
ad assorbire sempre più questo stare
attento a non ferire l'altro a prendermi
le mie responsabilità
lo sport la squadra sono anche un vivere
in simbiosi nel momento in cui l'altro
va in difficoltà tu devi essere così
lucido da lavorare anche per lui da
esserci anche per lui da spronarlo ad
essere nuovamente pronto in campo la
pallavolo appunto mi ha insegnato ad
esserci per l'altro e io questo non me
lo sarei mai aspettato da uno sport
esserci per qualcun altro comprendere la
sua difficoltà fargli capire che ci sei
passato anche tu è che tutto si risolve
solo se prova in sé la volontà di
riscattarsi soprattutto per se stesso la
pallavolo mi ha dato anche la
possibilità di vedermi in un gruppo un
gruppo che col tempo è cambiato come
sono cambiato io ho visto compagni di
squadra e andarsene altri aggiungersi
amicizie nascere e stupirmi di ciò
perché se uno sport da origine anche ad
amicizie sincere e profonde
allora è quello giusto capitano dei
giorni in cui durante o dopo allenamento
6 a terra
magari la giornata andata male malissimo
oppure non ti sei allenato come avessi
potuto ed è allora lì quando tutto
sembra che vada per il peggio
nei giorni no che tu dicevi di più da
uno sport quando meno te lo aspetti uno
sport non ti forma soltanto a livello
agonistico cioè come atleta era quello
che pensano in tanti uno sport di forma
come uomo inteso proprio come essere
umano che se tu veramente lo vivi lo
sport non può che rimanerne fuori
e allora vinci vinci partite vinci
titoli regionali arrivi a gareggiare
alle finali nazionali vinci borse di
studio grazie ad una squadra
perché io non avrei mai vinto premi del
genere se non avessi fatto parte di
quella squadra con quei compagni se quei
compagni non avessero continuato a
credere in me se quella passione che era
nata dentro di me non fosse continuato
ad esistere
non avrei mai capito che tutti i miei
sforzi ma avrebbero portato qualcosa di
concreto di bello perché per quanto
possa essere banale questo aggettivo
eppure esprime molto più di quanto si
possa immaginare
la bellezza di dire ce l'ho fatta una
frase che poche volte ci rivolgiamo con
sincerità mi ricordo ancora quando era
ai primi anni di pallavolo e la panchina
era la mia migliore amica per tre lunghi
anni sono stato in panchina se entriamo
in campo era soltanto per gli ultimi
punti quando ormai le sorti non potevano
essere cambiate ribaltate
nonostante mancassero poche azioni al
termine le mie gambe tremavano prima
vano perché io volevo dimostrare
qualcosa e non riusciva a stare fermo mi
dicevo paolo ma vuoi stare fermo quasi a
rimproverarmi di questo timore
tanti mi dicevano stai tranquillo è solo
una partita per me non era solo una
partita per me era finalmente il momento
di far vedere quanto io valessi di far
vedere che c'ero anch'io di essere
finalmente un paolo capace di portare se
stesse la propria squadra raggiungimento
di un obiettivo comune che in quel
momento era semplicemente vincere una
partita con altri ragazzini di 11 12
anni
ricordo ancora quando
era un po più debole e assogas tar mi
come adesso succede a volte era il non
ci riesco non ci riesco
ricordo ancora quello che mi disse un
mio compagno di squadra un giorno quando
ero in sicuro ancora non sapevo giocare
bene bene a pallavolo era il sicuro non
solo nel campo da pallavolo ma in ogni
campo della mia vita disse se tu già
prima di tentare tc non ci riesco allora
non ce la farai mai
è lì che sbagli da quel momento è
cambiato di molto il modo di vedere le
cose di trovare in me la forza di
cambiarmi no non per gli altri per me
per me
da allora mi sono sempre ripetuto io non
devo nulla a nessuno ma messi io devo la
rivincita a me stesso e voi immaginerete
che io da ragazzino imbranato e insicuro
sia improvvisamente diventato forte
consapevole sicuro di chi volevo essere
che nessuno avrebbe più messo i piedi in
testa
no ma vi pare
e mica paolino quello che è successo con
gli occhialoni rossi un po goffo poteva
fare una cosa del genere io ero uno tra
gli ultimi uno di quelli poco popolari
uno di quelli che se ci sono o meno non
cambia poi tanto non ero neanche nemmeno
per me stesso come potevo immaginare di
farmi valere tra gli altri così sicuri
amati ma nella pallavolo lo trovavo il
modo di essere me stesso di essere
qualcuno di urlare quando facevo un
punto un muro era il mio modo per
sfogarmi per dire ci sono anch'io
e guarda caso valgo quanto te
fino adesso vi ho dipinto lo sport come
qualcosa di magnifico riscatto amicizia
un modo per trovare la propria identità
credere in sé ma anche lo sport come
tutto ciò che ci circonda ai suoi
risvolti negativi aspetti che quando era
ancora un bambino non credevi si
sarebbero mai potuti rivelare la
pallavolo è stata ed è anche deludere
avere paura di deludere gli altri i tuoi
genitori te stesso la pallavolo è uno
sport di squadra e come dicevo ci sono
anche delle riserve to lotti per giocare
ti impegni penetrare titolare sin dal
primo punto che quando sei lì su quel
campo che puoi dare dimostrazione di
tutto ciò che hai fatto che è l'errore
che ti spaventa la paura di non far
vedere agli altri che tu meriti senza
alcuna ombra di dubbio di essere lì
ed è qui che subentra al ruolo della
amici della fiducia
quello che io reputo più importante che
per quanto potente possa essere è allo
stesso tempo la cosa più facile in ogni
relazione situazione della nostra vita
ma se tutti credono che tu possa
riuscirci se tu trovi la fiducia non
solo in te stesso ma negli altri che
allora vinci non solo partite ma tutti i
dubbi e ti lasci alle spalle tutti quei
momenti della settimana in cui ti eri
lasciato abbattere la fiducia che gli
altri avevano riposto in me e che io
avevo riposto in me stesso è stata più e
più volte ripagata
ma è nel 2017 ho avuto la conferma che
vale la pena di credere nelle nostre
possibilità
cosa è successo allora tipica ora del
secondo superiore sui promessi sposi e
dalla bidella e classi buongiorno
caprotti paolo in segreteria
ok va bene allora
chiede il permesso per uscire sceglie le
scale e intanto ti chiedi perché tu
giustamente non te lo ricordi di esserti
iscritto alla borsa di studio e adesso
che devo fare io
io non faccio mai niente di male una
volta entrato e comunicatami la vittoria
non potevo crederci
yo yo che vinceva un premio qualcosa io
che vinceva un piano col miglior
studente atleta insieme ad altra ragazza
del mio stesso liceo una cosa che non
succedeva da anni
e allora lì che ho capito che studiare
fino all'una di notte per caputo
allenamento fino a tardi è sentito
qualcosa piangere sopra una versione di
greco a mezzanotte perché ho avuto un
allenamento che ha occupato tutto
l'intero pomeriggio e arrivare a un
livello di esasperazione assurdo
potete immaginare è servito a qualcosa
in quel momento ho capito che se una
persona lo vuole può fare tutto
spesso i miei coetanei mi girano mi
chiedono come faccio a fare dal lavoro
teatro essere educatori in oratorio
studiare fare il liceo classico che
quando dice il liceo classico la gente
ti guarda maggio
e allora lì io rispondo semplicemente lo
faccio e basta
eh si io lo faccio e basta perché se una
persona veramente la vuole fare una cosa
la fa se invece tu già parti affermando
tanto non troverei il tempo beh allora
non credo che riuscirai mai a dare
spazio alle tue passioni
a ciò che ti rende realmente felice
nella vita io sono creato per le
meritorie e per le mie sconfitte reato
ai miei genitori amici insegnanti
compagni di squadra compagni di scuola
io devo le mie vittorie ad altri non
solo a me stesso perché una vittoria non
è mai solo ed esclusivamente per se uno
vince con qualcun altro e per qualcun
altro grazie
[Applauso]